[Music]
when i was in college we had a tradition
where we would scratch lotto tickets and
then go to breakfast sunday breakfast at
place called the big tomato in
poughkeepsie shout out and i never
really won on scratch lotto i would
occasionally get like a dollar
maybe two dollars i think was the most i
won or like a free ticket but one time i
scratched off and i had won a thousand
dollars and at the time i was like a
starving college student on financial
aid and all that not boom starving no no
no
i was at breakfast in fact
that's a bad figure of speech i think
that's an offensive that should be
offensive should we cancel it i think we
should cancel cancelled i just didn't
whatever i didn't have that much money
and so i was really excited and
for 30 seconds i i thought i had won and
then i showed somebody the ticket and
they were like what are you talking
about you didn't get three of the
cherries you know you only got two and
what
i just read it wrong but it was a lesson
in not you know setting yourself up to
fail no what was the lesson you're full
of pearls
let's get let's get more of them okay
here we go
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short
i'm your wise so
justin like
[Music]
and with me as always is um my brother
christian who
i feel like you've won money in the
lottery no in the lottery the lottery
than the lotto scratch lotto
you wouldn't know if i won the lottery i
would tell you yeah
what have you just been sitting on that
i've never won the lottery i i don't
think i've won a lot in the scratch-offs
you know like five dollars here or there
i'm trying to remember what i i still
remember it's very exciting to win
though so that 30 seconds where you
thought you won must have been a great
experience it was that's the interesting
thing but but when you the 30 seconds
after you exactly lost it was like did
it did it overwhelm the good
30 seconds yes to the point where sure
they didn't cancel each other out the
bad outweigh the game exactly and so is
as if i had lost something which i never
had i guess that's the lesson but why is
the negative expectation half half of
the equation
dominant for you than the positive first
half well because that's the part what
does that say about you well the
negative part is the one that lasted had
it been reversed had i thought i lost
and then realized i won
the lasting
effect would be that i won yeah but
finding out you lost when you thought
you won shouldn't last because you
should be able to quickly tell yourself
oh i only thought i won for 30 seconds
that's true maybe it didn't last as long
as i'm remembering but it did it did
it affected me i was like i felt like i
had lost something but it was something
i never really had
so it's something to chew on but there
have been versions like that in my life
since then where it's like i had a story
about something that i had committed to
that i was
that i took to be a
gospel that i took that you know that i
really like invested in are you still
meditating yes is it working it is i
think it yeah in fact there have been a
few instances where um
i was traveling a lot recently and um
travel especially around the holidays
especially with uh the new
variant oh man [ __ ] omnicron i don't
want to bring home omicron why don't i
say omnicron that sounds like a
transformer yeah
excuse me i'm a little sick
it's a greek letter i'm not covet i
don't have covert i've been getting
tested to brag no i've been um
that's offensive to people who do have i
know i i didn't mean to cancel cancelled
[ __ ] but i i was in toronto uh shout out
by the way to amelia rogers uh listener
of the show yes and her son bodie who um
hooked me up with this line skate job
shout out to lions oh she did yeah oh
cool isn't that cool um so it's a lot of
fun uh horror movie up in toronto but
traveling a lot has been uh it's been
wear and tear on my little sister well
you have a pretty fragile immune system
to begin with yeah hey why are we
talking about uh your good fortune of
winning the lottery or uh your bad
fortune of finding out that you didn't
yeah and be of traveling a lot and being
frustrated i'm curious um well i'll tell
you we are talking about my good and bad
fortune fortunes of all
the whole spectrum of fortune because
our guest today
is name fortune what a tie-in and what a
great name fortune
when i hear for its fortune feamster is
our guest very funny guest um but i was
gonna say when i hear fortune i i don't
know why i automatically
assume good fortune
hmm do you i to me fortune is a positive
name but it shouldn't necessarily for me
too you both don't have you don't have
to think that
the fortune is inherently positive when
it could easily be negative but a
fortune suggests that you have it that
you have the fortune and it's not
something right it's only negative if
it's preceded by
bad yeah like or no yeah but who says no
fortune
um bad fortune i have the bad for i'm
the misfortunes parents when she
misbehaved i had the misfortune
bad fortune
stupid
uh yeah i'm surprised i didn't do more
well you'll hear um i can brag about not
having done more bits about her name at
the end so fortune feamster yeah i for a
long time i thought her name was
pronounced fortune feimster so did i you
know both everything fortune thieves are
saying it was fortune feinster
it looks more like fortune five star to
me it does because there's an eye in it
it's a misleading eye
it's f-e-i-m-s-t-e-o
yeah t-e-o
fine i guess
is it german
i don't know maybe i'll ask her we're
interviewing her her name is fortune
feemster and she has
among other things a very funny netflix
hour-long you just spilled water all
over your pants yes i was gonna let it
go right on the garage i couldn't not
comment no you excitedly
you said it it wasn't just a little
dribble it was like an explosion of
water out of your mouth i don't know
that was weird
it's all over my crotch really wet
crotch right now listeners just so you
know so fortune feebster i had the bad
fortune of having a wet crush you had
the misfortune of having a wet penis
area misfortune
um so speaking of weapons areas
she has a very funny hour-long netflix
special
called sweet and salty that we both
watch together it's very funny
and um and she she does a lot of things
she's in a lot of she's an actress sorry
i just can't get past wet penis area
that should be the chapter of uh
we can't say that uh sure why not yeah
hey can i hear from fortune 50 yeah sure
okay here we go fortune feamster uh the
very funny you'll hear uh you know she's
droll and she's gotta draw
very funny here she is fortune themester
life
hello hello
[Music]
where are you exactly i'm in los angeles
this is one of my rare weeks at home
oh nice
i've started my tour
and have been all over so i'm just so
happy to be sleeping in my bed right now
i bet isn't that nice when you can like
i know oh so so lovely it's like one of
those things you don't realize how
lovely to like what an experience that
is until you've been away for a while
yeah well i got really spoiled a year
and a half off of the road um
when the when it first happened
i was like oh my gosh i need to get out
of here i've got to be on the road i've
been touring for
11 years
god yeah and uh i got really used to
being at home and then i was like now i
don't want to leave yeah i know it's so
wonderful to be home but i know the
gates open back up and what did you miss
about touring i mean what was like the
first thing that comes to mind well i
don't i just think as a stand-up we
never thought in a million years we
wouldn't be able to do our jobs right
whenever there was any sort of tragedy
in the world or the country
stand up was always the place you would
go to yeah to
feel better or to laugh or even just
like be like feel like you're all in
this together totally and it was the
first time that we could not do our jobs
like isn't that wild yeah just shut it
just everything just shut down were you
doing any version of like i know a lot
of like friends were doing zoom stuff
and
doing like instagram lives were you
doing that kind of stuff for the first
couple months i didn't do anything i i
filmed a bunch of videos like in like
one day
then like released them over like three
months to like allow to allow myself to
just be
sad and down yeah but also the
entertainer in me was like but you still
have to
right i gotta get out people laugh yes
yeah then i got then i started doing
like some of the zoom shows was that
hard to do without i i imagine for a
stand-up to not receive any energy from
like of a better word from an audience
but how does that change things how
different is that well you just had to
really learn to be that much more
comfortable being on stage because it
was the zoom shows and the car shows
both of which you couldn't hear much
laughter oh yeah
so for so you really had to just trust
that if you're not funny or at least
interesting you're like there's
i have to trust that something of what
i'm doing is okay which of those whoever
is watching that must be hard that much
i mean i would imagine that just
requires confidence in your material and
because i i i would think that the few
times i've like
dabbled slightly in that world or like
the outskirts of it i
if i don't hear i didn't want something
the other night at this charity event
where i just had to get up and say
something like that
i was hoping to be funny it was like the
aim of being funny and
i i didn't get a reaction and i
immediately became um
insecure you know i could feel myself
like getting nervous and like start
talking faster like huh
yeah
and like reminded me of like
it it brought me right back to
those early moments of like trying to
perform in high school or where you know
when you're in front of a group um yeah
do you have if you don't hear that
feedback like how do you process that
like you have material that you think is
funny and you just get like crickets
what what does that feel like i mean it
doesn't feel great no one
no one loves that
i think you know after those shows you
you know in a normal show
you've gotten something out of it
they've gotten something out of it you
know you're riding off of the feeling of
all that laughter you're like oh my god
your soul feels very fulfilled
so coming off of those shows when you
don't hear any laughter yeah it doesn't
mean they weren't laughing but you know
they were getting something out of it
which was great and that's what you
wanted but you had to just be okay with
like yeah that was something you know
uh so you didn't like leave with that
same um like you're you're not on like a
high your cup wasn't runneth over
yes with energy and feelings yeah so it
just was it i think it felt more sad
four stand-ups at the time to just be
like uh is this what it's gonna be like
i think there was a fear of like is this
it is this
where we're headed for a long time
i bet yeah i bet it was um and so did
you do your netflix special suite it's
so funny by the way i want to talk about
it thank you it's really great it's very
autobiographical it just felt very
honest and um
was that something you did during the
pandemic or was that no thankfully it i
shot it in a late 2019
oh oh wow
and it came out about a month before
everything shut down
so yeah it was like fall
fall of 2019
it came out um
late january early february
uh so i had like a minute of getting to
like promote it
and
uh see the billboard out in the world
yeah you know times square
um billboards and stuff that's cool
that was really awesome you take
pictures and stuff it's not bad
yeah i took pictures because you know
i had done two half hours before but
this was my first hour
and you know you just hope people watch
it and
i was getting like really great feedback
and then the world just like shut down
and we had just put a tour up for se for
on sale and six months of theater sold
out like right away
which is great but then yeah you were i
was like oh my god finally like wow this
is so cool my first show was this is
like march 11th
of 2020. yeah listen no one had a great
year no i know i know that's that's the
thing about like lamenting things like
that right you don't want to like
complain too much because like
we're [ __ ] alive you're alive and
that's that ends up being what mattered
and
the you know if there is a silver lining
in it it's that a lot of people found it
during the
shut during that shutdown i bet i i i
know i've been finding it very hard to
talk about any silver linings or
anything positive during this time
because it's like right you know we all
went through this like eggs collective
like existential dread which has also
put everything in perspective um
for me anyway i don't want to speak for
the collective but how has it affected
you i mean your outlook on the world has
it
what did it do to your consciousness and
how you saw the world i mean it
definitely made you stop and go well
what you know what matters yeah you know
yeah i love working i love
you know doing my job but like
is your home life good is your
relationship right totally how are your
friends are you checking in with your
family like life became
more important because you saw how
fragile it could be and
you know
that something like this could stop all
of us in our tracks
sort of made the ground underneath us
shakier right
because before you could always just be
like
it's
it's going to work out yeah everything's
fine yeah everything's fine because you
can kind of will yourself
into
that positive thinking when there's a
worldwide pandemic nothing is in your
control yeah yeah so i think it the
fragility of i know it's so
heavy but the friction no no i started
it the fragility of life really
you saw how
fragile totally it is
did it strengthen your because
especially you talk about having gotten
married and it's a really funny story
about how you
you both had the same thought when you
were watching a well i'll let you tell
but you were watching a murder like a
murder documentary yeah we made a pact
to each other
early on in our relationship that we
wouldn't murder each other yeah because
we we kept watching dateline together i
think a lot of women love murder
podcasts and shows
so we were watching dateline and it kept
the the recurring theme i don't know if
we were just watching
these particular ones but it was always
like um
you know they went out on a date or they
met it you know it was always like
early on
and then suddenly yeah things were great
and then like they didn't know who that
per who they were with yes murder
and um so we kind of it started like
freaking us out like
like do you really know who you're with
when you meet somebody and it's so easy
as good as it can be it's like
everything's great it's almost like when
it's better
you know then you start worrying that
like when's the other shoe gonna right
you know right are they gonna reveal
their murderous intentions and it and we
didn't realize that we were both kind of
having that thought at the same time
so he like looked at each other and
you're like promise me you're never
going to murder me
and uh we shook on it and uh that's what
they go back on that yeah then you think
well a murderer would probably not be
the most more i mean they probably
wouldn't like take that very seriously
uh how if the person goes i'm not
shaking on that then
yeah
that's more than a red flag
you must be so sick of answering this
fortune but your name is great but where
did they come from fortune
so it's my middle name and
it is my great grandmother's maiden name
so we have a lot of fortunes in our
family but with the last name fortune
okay so my so my grandma it was my
grandmother's mom uh and so she she and
her she had three sisters with four of
them with the last name fortune and they
called him the misfortunes
that's awesome that's right so my
grandmother rascals were they like
trouble yeah they were trouble
and uh
my grandmother really really wanted my
my mom to name me fortune
and my mom was like it's too big of a
name
she would have to be miss america to
live up to a name like that it's a big
name it is a big name it's a big name so
it's like she would need a billboard in
times square to have a name like that a
hundred percent and uh so i ended up
growing up going by my name my first
name emily
um it wasn't until i moved to la
and it was after my grandmother died it
was sort of uh my way of
um
paying homage to
or hon what is it the word you know
oh my hom age homage homage whatever
that word is yeah yeah
paying a little nod to my grandmother a
little tip of the hat a tip of the hat i
started going by fortune
and i think i thought that you could be
one thing on stage and
eventually it was like almost
immediately everyone was like fortune
fortune fortune
and i really felt like that felt more
authentic uh yeah well it's also like so
memorable i mean it is like it's great
to have you know people remember that
name fortune uh you probably don't meet
many
fortunes i don't know have you ever met
another one i have had like a few people
write me uh i've met like one
person with a first name fortune but
several people the last name fortune uh
have written to me but yeah it was my
grandmother that really
instilled the confidence in me that
i could even do something like this and
she was such a big influence on me and
the fact that she all like she wanted me
to be named fortune from day one yeah
yeah made me feel like she always saw
something in me totally i had not seen
yet so did she ever get to watch you
perform
no she doesn't she died when i was 18.
oh man the day that she died the day i
moved into college
um and
uh
i did not start theater until my
sophomore year of college
and why was that what was it about had
you been interested in it before but
was it something you had thought about
before or was how did you get into it i
mean i didn't really realize that i
loved comedy but
in hindsight i was like obsessed with
saturn live i watched it religiously
every weekend
i would tape
the shows on the vhs tape sure and just
rewind it rewind it watch it over and
over again it's me too i started with
the
adam sandler chris farley days
yes and that that was i was always
listening like adam's uh
album that comedy album
yeah i learned it by heart and then my
high school years was going into the
will ferrell yeah molly shannon cherio
terriers so a lot of those silly
big performers
influenced me yeah yeah pretty heavily
but i didn't i didn't have
there wasn't really theater
where i was huh um
so i didn't find it till college
in north carolina because i know you're
special you say you grew up it's so cool
you got to do the special
30 you say 30 minutes from where you
grew up and yeah um
and
so what type of high school was that was
it like a typical
suburban higher yeah typical small town
yeah typical small town high school
where everybody knows each other the big
friday night football games where
everybody goes and how did you fit into
that world what was that experience like
um i
think i used humor even back then to
that's how i made friends i was the
person that bopped around to
a lot of different friend groups yeah
yeah kind of making everybody laugh but
i wasn't necessarily like the class
clown like i was never the like hey all
eyes on me
um but i would have moments you know
where i would be silly so so you had
confident i mean you must have had a lot
of confidence then i think so i i at
least
i was was at least self-aware enough to
know
even back then that
i knew like boys weren't looking at me
and i wasn't like the object of
affection in that way
so i was like
what is it about me that you know
i can use to
have someone
pay attention to me or right
be friends with me and that was usually
my personality i was like so let me just
lean into that more yeah well um you
know it worked out for sure
you know the the odds were not in my
favor but i've been lucky to
have you know i mean 18 years in la
wow a lot of people
that look like me do not get on
television yeah um so you know it was a
long road but
i'm so lucky to be doing what i do well
for was it difficult for you in that
environment in that because and maybe
this is my own prejudice about like
small small southern towns but was it
difficult for you to be
your authentic self you you talk about
being so funny and especially talk about
being in the girl scouts and like being
in a room full of girls and how
appealing that was and like giving them
shoulder massages and stuff but like you
then say you didn't know for sure that
you were you were gay until you which is
also very funny you saw the lifetime
movie yeah um i i i'm gonna try to not
rehash everything and the special people
should just watch it but it's um
what
how did you
or did you struggle with that was that
did you were you confused during that
time or was it something that you kept
from people because of the environment
that you lived in right
i
it sounds so naive to say now but i
truly truly did not know i was gay it
was it wasn't like i was in the closet
yeah um i think a lot of that is because
it was a different time right it was um
yeah a time where communication
was not the same you know we didn't have
cell phones i'm like sound like i'm 100
years old no no i'm with you i know but
we didn't have cell phones i think i got
a cell phone my like senior year of
college
um so so we didn't have personal devices
youtube had not
been invented there was not will and
grace yeah there wasn't you didn't talk
about gay people right yeah so i knew
what gay was but it was like
i didn't know how that applied to me
i knew i had feelings towards certain
friends here and there
but i just thought it was like regular
teenage angst like right
like in my very first half hour i used
to do a joke of where i would say you
know i was very intense about friends
and my mom would be like i don't
understand why you get so upset when
your friend michelle goes out on a date
with a guy and i was like because she's
my best
friend
and
it was like summed up all the angst yeah
that's interesting
well even when like you talk about
watching baywatch you're like you're
into baywatch like yeah how would you
how would you articulate
the fortune at that age like her her
interest in baywatch like what was it
like you love lifeguards
yeah it was more just like oh that's a
pretty girl you know just yeah all right
and i would just kind of like
clock it but not really like that digest
it yeah not digest it and things weren't
things weren't really sexualized as much
back then i know right again that sounds
so naive but
that those were the times i was from a
town of like 10 000 people wow and you
know it just was i didn't know gay
people it was yeah anyone i thought
might be gay was like in in the closet
or married to like a person of the
opposite sex
so it was not on the radar and and even
in college i went to a women's college
everyone's like how did you not no
right yeah it was a lot of the girls
there were like
they uh nc state was like five minutes
away it was
predominantly
uh not predominantly there's a lot of
men that go there because it's an
engineering school
so they were always coming to our school
looking for wives
so girls were there for husbands yeah
so it was not like a gay
women's college where people were like
growing their arm see i went to vassar
oh gotcha which yeah kind of was you
know we had a thing there in fact called
and this is like the late 90s which is
like seems so progressive now uh we
there was that there was a thing that
happened they were called they called
them lugs or bugs which was lesbian
until graduation oh and bisexual
undergraduation and then you see like
very clearly i mean i i i say that not
wanting to be offensive but like you
know somebody who's clearly gay at the
time and then years later they're they
seem so that this is my husband and very
traditional like sound different and
like interesting
it was
like the biggest dance their fortune was
called the homo hop that was like
yeah this is like the late 90s yeah it
was um to me it was great because it was
like i grew up in a very traditional
you know suburban
the chocks were on the top of the food
chain and all that and like a lot of it
and and so this was
now the like theater nerds and then like
the comedy geeks were like
we're like the the cool kids you know
it was totally reversed yeah it's just
you know it's interesting because now
it's like
you turn on your tv you see a lot more
representation kids on tick tock
everyone like a lot of kids are coming
out really young they know they have a
sense of who they are
but that's truly
representation has pushed that forward
yeah and you know when you can see
yourself represented in so many places
you immediately clock that and you go oh
i am yeah that resonates with me i feel
that you know and they're there there
it's okay for them to be out there yeah
so i just didn't have that and uh it
wasn't until i moved to la that that oh
really started bubbling up who was there
somebody in i mean was that was that pre
ellen was that
was she even ellen had yeah ellen had
come out um and i remember that vaguely
i was young i think i was
i want to say 14. yeah so i was like
kind of watching it kind of not you know
like i i like pop culture wasn't a big
thing
where i grew up so it was like you sort
of knew that she came out but she also
knew that it didn't go well
yeah and then you sort of clocked that
too of like well that
you know she oh she came out whoa she's
on the cover of tom wow
oh she got fired no okay
you know that yeah like that's what
that's all you're taking in she came out
it's a big deal oh now she lost her job
oh
yeah
so
it's not totally okay exactly yeah i do
remember like
rosie o'donnell's talk show
i think that was like in college and i
was i would be like why did she keep
talking about tom cruise
i remember that ellen two would often on
her show she's she would like fetishize
like attractive guys i don't know about
tom cruise but like oh my god it's
justin timberlake she's really really
really good really yeah um
and that might that would have been
confusing to me right
because but also back then like
everything was so binary you know so if
you were gay you were gay but i remember
at faster they they really promoted that
the kinsey theory which was like the
spectrum like
from one to six yeah and that sexuality
was fluid and that was really revelatory
to me um
yeah
so so when you did when you do go to la
is it like
and and it and i imagine like it
corresponds with when you
saw this lifetime movie and realize that
you were gay was it like was it like a
light switch was it like a media
a few things started happening that were
leading up to that clearly it was
becoming to the point where i couldn't
ignore it anymore that that stuff was
bubbling up inside of me and i was
curious so
the l word had just come out and i i
didn't have show time because we were
broke
and um
this was
i mean all of this feels so ancient now
so craigslist was super popular yeah so
you you could buy like bootleg dvds off
of craigslist oh my god yeah so i i
bought the bootleg season one l word
and i went i didn't tell anyone i bought
it but really like i are you feel like
when you do that are you feeling like is
there shame attached to it is there any
like religious stuff is it like yeah and
more secrecy of like i can't tell anyone
yeah i'm buying this i have to watch
family stuff like what is my family
gonna think yeah like you just you feel
like you're
you have this big secret yeah and you
don't know what to do with it and you're
like i don't know how i don't even know
what to do with it so what are other
people going to think of it right so i
like you know closed my door locked it
so funny i watched it with like no one
at home because i had two roommates of
course he's in la you have two roommates
for like ever yeah and it blew my mind i
was like oh my god you know like all the
things inside of me were just like what
but i still wasn't like
processing that that's me i still wasn't
like ah i just interesting yeah i was
still just like whoa look at these like
just seeing two women kiss like that was
huge i've never really seen them yeah
isn't that yeah
seeing women seeing lesbians get coffee
together i had not seen that
that's how naive and what a small town i
was from what so that was like a
monumental
thing towards
towards that and then yeah i remember it
was gay pride in l.a i drove down there
got out of my car
saw people in all these crazy outfits
turned right back around got back in my
car and left that's so funny why do you
think i think i was just scared i was
that was terrified but then that
lifetime movie was next it i could not
deny it any longer that was the catalyst
yeah thanks life yeah tv for women
[Music]
during the holiday season if you need a
little break from the holiday action
from family or whatever you want to just
kind of go off on your own and you need
to play a little fun game check out best
fiends
best fiends is a casual mobile apostle
game it's about matching things and
playing puzzles and there's an amazing
storyline and collectible fiends and
there's tons of fun puzzles to download
it's one of those games that's hard to
put down so it's free to download
and there are a hundred million
downloads so that should give you an
idea of how fun and popular it is it's
also not just for kids who says kids
should have all the fun
if you're an adult and you're playing
it's it's got that effect that it makes
you feel like a kid again which is a
great way to feel you can share it with
your own friends or your own fiends and
you can play anywhere you don't even
need wi-fi you can download best fiends
free today on the app store or google
play that's friends without the r so
best fiends best fiends check it out
over a hundred million people can't be
wrong
and um and see what you think like i
said it's it's free the fiends are free
and so you can just check it out for
yourself
our sponsor hunter killer is a murder
mystery subscription box where you play
as a detective who's solving a case and
i'm telling you it really does feel like
you're the lead detective in a real life
investigation well your lover is a huge
fan of those murder mysteries of the
dateline a lot of people are i know she
was very excited about this and she's we
had a great time with it yeah you guys
have even been playing together it was
it's so fun and it's also a great active
thing
your brain it sure does yeah and in all
their games you can sift through the
documents evidence audio recordings and
case files until you
solve the murder you do it alone but i
think it's more fun to do with friends
or family it's like a board game but
complete with complex puzzles and
exciting story lines right because
that's kind of what it is that's what
those detectives do yeah is solve a
puzzle you feel like you're in one of
those shows we really love this part
part of the proceeds go to the cold case
foundation to help solve and support the
victims of real cases right it is also
going to help these real-life cases and
support the victims of such cases so
kind of a win-win so right now you can
go to huntakiller.com
justin
and use code justin for ten dollars off
your purchase again make sure to use
code justin hunt a killer dot com slash
justin for a ten dollar discount
[Music]
i remember fortune going to l.a for the
first time this is 99 i think it's the
first job i had and acting and um
doing this movie and they put me up at
um that the la montrose hotel on hammond
and uh it was on sunset and so and i
didn't have a car they i didn't rent a
car or anything so like on my days off i
would just naturally walk downhill yeah
and and
hollywood west hollywood's like yeah the
heart of west hollywood and
i i remember talking to friends they
were like you know what's la like how
was it and i remember saying like it's
very gay i love it very good people are
so friendly you know it's like um but i
i likewise i had never i'm not from a
smaller town as you but i had never seen
men holding hands and walking around
showing affection um
it must have been really yeah i can only
imagine what that must have done to your
brain when you were trying to process
i mean i i i realized that i was gay but
still had no gay friends
i did not know anyone because to be
truth be told i didn't have many friends
at all
at the time because i was new to l.a so
it was just hard to make friends so how
did you find your roommates was that a
craigslist thing too craigslist yeah
yeah all right shout out to crazy this
is a real this is like one big ad for
christmas i know i like did everything
off of craigslist back then yeah
yeah i just uh i had i i kind of was
like oh now i realize that i'm gay but
now it really was like now what now what
what do i do i don't know any gay people
so i had to just like i started joining
all these sports teams i know that's
very cliche but i know i was like
there's gonna be one lesbo on that
softball team i know it yes there has to
be you join the one like totally
straight the softball team right yeah
so i did end up meeting gay people and
they're they're the ones that really
open
the world to me they were kind of my my
get gay fairy godmothers yes and um
my mom and i actually i went to a
wedding and it could just be fairy
godmothers you know
that's that's true fairy fairy godmother
um gay fairy gay mothers yeah um
my mom and i went to a good friend's
wedding in boston and like like may like
a year later i had come out at this
point i told her
and she was she what did she say what
was her reaction i mean she was more of
just uh
listening
i think for her she was just she didn't
want life
to be harder for me than it yeah yeah
can be you know naturally is for your
kid yeah she knew that
how people treated gay people at the
time
and i think hers was more of like i
can't protect you
it's people are going to hate you
for no reason and that
really made her sad
uh but she accepted me and and my whole
family was great about it she ended up
becoming
the president of my
hometown p flag this it's a parent
organization that's like gay allies
um for like 10 years that's amazing yeah
so she's been incredible but we went to
this wedding and so we
we ended up traveling around that rhode
island and um
all right my mom goes it's a gay enclave
and i'm like what
she kept calling it a gay on flame
and uh i had never heard of it this is
how but how much of a baby why do you
keep
[Laughter]
we were like let's go have dinner there
you know we were just kind of bopping
through the area
and we we kind of turned a corner and
there suddenly there's like all these
gay people everywhere everywhere
holding hands which obviously in my many
years now of being gay it's like second
nature yeah when you were newly gay from
the small town my mom and i both had
never seen anything like it my mom kept
going look look
they're gay people everywhere i'm like
mom be quiet
yeah you know
we sounded crazy yeah you sound like you
were like infiltrating it's like
yeah it's like
try to be cool i remember my grandma who
um was on the show friend of the show
she's since passed away but she was just
like a lovely person and um so warm and
open but like she just didn't
have the experience she hadn't seen gabe
i remember seeing uh
two women holding out like being very
affectionate at a restaurant and she was
fascinated she wasn't not in a judgy
like negative way she was just like it
was like she was seeing like [ __ ]
unicorn you know like oh my like she was
seeing like bigfoot like oh my god like
anthropologically like studying them
like she'd never seen it and she was
just
fascinated if you haven't seen it it's
very like whoa you know
and like like you say it's not in a
judgy way or a hateful way it's new
even i was like whoa i've never seen
this before and it's a really beautiful
thing you see people just living their
life yeah being happy no one's and
they're not scared which is how it
should be
you know it's a safe place and
my mom went in this in the one of the
chocolate shops and got fudge oh there's
a fight there's a fudge shop there i
know exactly what you're talking about
and i remember thinking like that's kind
of scary i wonder if people make jokes
about like because they're literally
guys
packing fun packing fudge
and it requires no joke no joke just
people love fudge yeah my mom came out
outside and she has
there was a woman in there making eyes
with me
and i was like are you sure she wasn't
looking at your fudge
well they're very arrogant of you
sexually
maybe that says something about you yeah
she was feeling herself in town yeah
that's awesome
um i i also i read that
a good friend of mine was on um csi
miami shout out to john togo
with
emily proctor yeah
you were
emily's personal assistant i was for
like a minute i oh okay she uh she and i
met doing i was the student speaker at
my college graduation she was the
commencement speaker oh
we hit it off she ended up hiring me so
she is essentially how i got to lay oh
no um so i worked for her for like a
year
i was a terrible assistant
but also i was 23 years old had no i'm
from a tiny town i have
you know god going moving to l.a and not
knowing anything
i'm like flipping through thomas guides
trying to figure out where i'm going oh
remember that it was horrifying yeah
time before gps i'd be people like
younger listeners might not know there's
this big it was called the time scout it
was a big like map book of maps yeah
that's how you found your way through la
of all places you'd have to pull over
and like
it would be like c16 and you have to
like find this c map and yeah oh man i
remember that i used to rent cars from
this place called rent-a-wreck you
remember rent-a-wreck
it was like they were the cheapest cars
you get a car for like fifteen dollars a
day
they would have been wrecked yeah they
were like brag they were like basically
it was like the step before it was like
a hospice for cars you know it was like
right before
like that um yeah i remember those days
god gps yeah
yeah man well i had no business being in
charge of anyone's life
uh especially in la but you know you
have to look at it as like
it's what got me out here it was part of
my path was emily like was she like i i
like you a lot as a person but you're
just not good at this how did that
resolve itself i mean she had never had
an assistant before so it was a huge
learning curve for both of us we both
kind of didn't know what we were doing
is that when she was on csi
she was like her second season
and that show went on for like 11 12
seasons yeah so this was super early on
so wow she was figuring out what she
needed i was figuring out what i was
doing so it was a very transitional time
for both of us uh but you know it was
nice to have
some you know a fellow southerner oh
yeah opportunity out mississippi she's
also north carolina north carolina okay
yeah yeah um but but then how when were
your i'm also so fascinated by your you
were a gossip
reporter or like an entertainment
journalist yeah but you referred to as
like on your show you called it it was a
gossip hot gas
how did that come about and did did you
enjoy it was that i'm so curious about
because i've only seen it as like a more
negative thing i guess i've seen it in
like a majority um
we really weren't gossip colonists i
just like to use the word hot goss we
were on we were on the more like
legitimate side of it of like
like my
my job was to interview actors and
directors and musicians on the on the
phone so if someone had this is like
pre-podcast
many many years before podcast yeah um
we were part of the creator syndicate so
we were like in a hundred newspapers oh
okay we were in the original like
netscape rumor netscape and aos
remember all the
the stories about
like movies or tv shows or actors that
would be on those home pages yes you
didn't know who wrote them those a lot
of that was us oh wow and they're only
there were only three of us
oh no
yeah so we um so it wasn't like gossip
stuff it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
gossip at all i just like to say hot
glass because it made me laugh
uh so it was it was a very legitimate
journalism job um i got that randomly
because emily's
neighbor
wrote for the la daily news uh-oh and
well she goes i heard you can write
because of that graduation speech yeah
that emily and i met from
and uh she goes do you want to help me
out so i started covering premieres and
events in la for her
and then and that led
like six months later to this journal
like true journalism job and did you it
was that did you think that oh maybe
that'll be my path or in the back your
mind where you're always like
comedy is what i want to be doing this
is a means to an end well i hadn't
discovered comedy yet i discovered
comedy 2005
um because
i was out here i didn't i had like i
said had a hard time making friends
because ellie's just a tough
tough place
and i started taking improv
yeah
truly just to make friends as a hobby
and it quickly became a passion and so i
was very lucky the the ladies i wrote
for i like my job was like
uh that that was what was hard about the
assistant job you didn't know your hours
you never knew when you're supposed to
work you never that you're like on call
on call and that was not really for me
yeah with the journalism thing i knew
from nine to six yeah yeah nine to five
i was that was my job it ends then i
would go do improv class
and they were very like these lady i
worked for them for like six years they
were so supportive they were always like
we know like what your true passion is
oh how cool yeah and so that it truly
was like it allowed me to pay my bills
but also be like industry adjacent yeah
i was going to like cool events and yeah
interviewing like julie andrews and you
know mike myers it's like wow tom hanks
it was like really cool
yeah i bet people that you admire i mean
like those snl and mike myers you
mentioned like you grew up watching uh
and you also talk in the special about
how there's always like free food at
these events good food oh my god really
good food and you're right no one eats
it like i'm constantly grabbing stuff i
know it's the best i was shoving you
know i would be shoving
sliders in my face
sliders and sliders yes yes they were
like do you want to interview someone
oh yeah
hold on
but it's funny now that i'm on the other
end of it i have published this coming
up to me
i i went to the ted lasso premiere for
and one of the publicists was like oh my
god like they remember you made it you
know i remember you talking about comedy
back in the day i'm like i can't believe
you remember
that i did that i had an another
publicist on the plane she goes i'm
so-and-so you used to like i was one of
the first people like she asked me to
interview carrie washington back in the
day and like was so grateful
that i interviewed and now you know
carrie's a huge star but like
terry washington viola davis elizabeth
banks these were people that publicists
were like please will you interview
these up and coming and i'm like yeah
sure and you know
were you stars gal gadot
oh really
were there ever oh man i guess you can't
say names but they're like did you have
the experience of like people being kind
of like
like douchey or shitty and then like
years later you're like
you're hobnobbing with them i didn't
have a lot of that um yeah i people i
think there's something about my
southern accent
that kind of made it disarms people like
that i bet i bet it's really refreshing
to run into your honor i think they just
kind of like oh she's you know she's not
here for any other reason you know yeah
and you're sweet and personable i
imagine you bring out the best in people
yeah i think like yeah i think
uh m.c hammer was kind of short with me
once
[Laughter]
please hammer don't i go i think you
might need this interview
yeah yeah
but you know no one was ever but i don't
have any stories anyone just being mean
yeah yeah that's good uh well and
especially because you always think like
and it must give you um a much different
perspective now you have like a whole
new insight into like
when you're doing those things because
now you're probably doing those like red
carpet things and yeah uh you you know
what it is
i see the value of it
yeah i i understand the value of it i
think a lot of
people look at it as like uh i have to
talk to someone so yeah
you know
they're they're doing a job you have a
job
you have something they want
you know you need them to promote your
thing it's a mutually beneficial
relationship totally i i always
kind of enjoyed it i like talking to
people and the the the ones that were
difficult that i had um i kind of um got
a little squirrely around were the ones
that were clearly not
paying attention or clearly didn't care
right
in their defense like you know there
were times where you know
you you've been on that other end so you
know
uh when like
a a more famous person or somebody that
is more significant is coming up or what
it's this whole strange like frenzy of
getting to the best the biggest person
whatever and yeah i i was never that
person really so like um
you always felt that you know i often
felt that right yeah i get that too i
mean yeah there was one actress i won't
say who that was not not very nice to me
um because uh we
you know in in the job that we were
doing we were interviewing so many
actors and actresses like every day uh
and like i said there was only three of
us so there's only so much content you
could consume
um and and she was promoting a movie
and uh called
nice job
and um i had not gotten a chance to
watch it which
you know some people are very adamant
that you need to have seen this movie
before i talk to you yeah other people
are kind of like hey
watch it when you can totally i just
appreciate you promoting it she
like
like i asked like one question and she
was like did you watch it oh boy and i
was like um i wasn't gonna lie to her i
was like yeah i have not not yet and uh
she goes and she said something like
really mean and snarky and then got her
publicist on the phone and they're like
we're ending this interview oh
my
and i thought god
was
so and i will say she has not done a lot
of stuff since then
i feel like she might have been just a
difficult person maybe well that's also
yeah i mean like that then ends up
working out in you know people then
that has a way of working out i think
yeah working itself out do you have you
ever run into her since
no never mm-hmm
she would not even know it was me i was
on the phone it was so funny yeah but
that it's a it's another testament to
this is the only business i truly think
this is one of the only businesses where
you never know
whoever you're talking to will go you
know what oh my god
oh my god i know i've been in the
business twenty three four years and
like you know the people that i i'm god
i i the number of pas or assistants to
so and so and then like
they're running like [ __ ]
they're like running a network you're
like what would be nice yeah be nice to
everyone
and you should be nice to everyone
anyway but it is truly a business of
like people
get promotions and or or change paths or
they
there's no hierarchy to this business it
is like so you know someone's running an
errand one day and they could be you
know running the network
it's true it happens so fast i know and
you're right it shouldn't be i know i
you should just be nice to everyone it's
a lesson for life but it's not because
they might [ __ ] you over because you're
right
um but it does i think sometimes weed
out i think especially lately like
because there's so much content there's
so um and and with social media i think
that's kind of started to weed out the
people who were really difficult well i
think people are having less tolerance
for it yeah yeah and and it's it's
there's more transparency so like that
that behavior is starting to get uh yeah
yeah you can't hide it as much these
days because everything is recorded that
people talk people have their own
platforms now yeah if you're addicted to
somebody they get to go online and be
like hey that person's a dick totally
yeah you know whereas everything before
was kind of kept a little bit like more
insidery so
i just i do think the business is
shifting yeah and and bad behavior is
not it's still rewarded which it
shouldn't be but not i feel like it the
karma's kind of coming around sometimes
on that bad behavior i think so
you you've covered so much of your
life in um sweet and salty
what what do you is that daunting in the
sense that the next one do you ever
think like well what am i going to talk
about next i'm running out of stuff to
mine
that's where i was
when my special came out
i mean i will say that's the beauty of
stand up and why i want it to always be
a part of my careers because
it is it it definitely took me to
another level because it was the first
time people saw me for a whole hour
right and then they really got to know
me and they go she's funny or we didn't
know this about you and yeah it
showcased me in a way that nothing else
has ever showcased me so stand up is so
wonderful that it gives you the power to
tell your story that no acting job can
do yeah bad so once i put that out there
is this pressure of like well oh my god
i
i i
where do i
go from here and
i didn't have any like much of anything
to be honest for like a year well the
world shut down so yeah it hasn't been
the funniest year yeah it but it gave it
in a weird way it gave me some time to
figure out what
the next chapter i got i bet so
in the spring of this year i just
really
just sat i sat down and mined
my brain and stories and my life and i
have a whole new hour now okay um and uh
that's what i'm touring with and oh cool
yeah it's in the same vein of a lot of
stories a lot of i like that yeah
it's clearly it's what i love that it's
not uh they're not jokes it's it's very
it feels very personal and like you're
telling me you're a great storyteller
and i love hearing stories i love that
style yeah i think i've just sort of
realized that that's kind of where my
voice is yeah so i've carried this on
and the same
same
same similar storytelling is happening
now but it sort of picks up where that
left off like here's what's happened now
yeah this happened this happened this
happened and but it still pertains to my
life
do you workshop stuff with your wife is
she especially during the quarantine
is she and is she a good sounding board
for that stuff yeah we were like hiking
uh you know during that time when
they're like don't be near anyone
um and so we would like you know go in
the morning and hike just two of us and
we we would she would be like oh
remember that you know when this
happened to us like maybe that maybe
there's something wrong yeah what does
she do fortune
she is a kindergarten teacher oh that's
right you said that how cool yeah but
she is on hiatus right now because yeah
you know you get worn out being a
teacher and the the pandemic is like
no thanks so she's especially
kindergarten i know
yeah so she's like uh editing and
producing our podcasts and she's kind of
like a tour manager right now so she
keeps our lives together she must be
very patient to be a kindergarten
teacher i imagine yes sweet patient
person she's an amazing yeah she's
amazing people
people meet her they're like she's a
saint uh how did you meet how you guess
uh chicago pride oh well just at the
parade just started there was like a a
night like a
these lesbians put on like a an event
yeah and i was i had i had a show in
minneapolis the night before
my friends running the event asked me to
stop in and i was like yeah why not i'm
not doing anything
uh the rest of the weekend i have pride
i have pride yeah yeah i love gay things
yes
so we we met like right away
oh really i i was there like 10 minutes
and no kidding she walked up and
she walked up to you yeah her friend
wanted to meet me and
did she know you as a comedian
uh yeah she knew i was a comedian but
she was had been drinking and she she
did not care
her friend wanted a picture and oh
and she was like just go ask her like
just who cares yeah yeah she really like
liquid confidence yeah
uh so her friend got a picture
and she got a wife i was like hey who
are you
so we kept running into each other all
night so it just kind of
our our paths kept bringing us into each
other's worlds and then how quickly did
it become serious i'm so curious about
uh
i mean we i definitely left that weekend
going huh
this is like that didn't feel like
the typical someone you just kind of
meet and that's it like yeah i felt like
there was a lot more substance there
yeah and uh we texted she went to italy
for like three weeks with her mom and we
texted a lot while she was gone and then
she came out to visit for a week and
we were like huh this you know
this seems kind of
like
a thing yeah and then she came out like
another week and then it was within like
a month and a half oh wow oh we're like
dating right
yeah
that's yeah my my limited experience
with that is it it usually happens
really for me anyway it happens very
fast very fast and out of nowhere
because yes totally i was not having
much luck
meeting like uh a more substantial yeah
person i was dating it was like flings
yeah and
were you thinking like well maybe this
is just what i'm meant to do maybe this
is yeah i'm just wired for like kind of
more totally yeah i thought i thought
well i've been blessed
with a really
amazing job
and maybe that's what i get is like
that's where my blessings come yeah yeah
i'm like uh yeah i travel too i'm like a
road person yeah a carny
and i thought maybe the dating thing's
just always going to be a bit more of a
thorn
in the side then then have been a
blessing yeah and and then uh yeah i was
really getting kind of exasperated with
it to the point of just like i think
before i met her i was just like ugh i'm
not even trying anymore totally that's
the best place to be though i think yeah
when you give up the pursuit because in
la you know it's like
there's a lot of that like mentality of
people looking for the next best thing
yeah totally that kind of like you'll do
for now
finding that a lot yeah even
conversationally you know yeah they're
like looking over your shoulder who uh
who's walking in there yeah everybody's
like the grass is always greener out
here yes it was driving me crazy because
i wanted a more substantial thing and
yeah
there she was in chicago oh cool came
out of nowhere
are you do you guys want to have kids
i don't think so i think
you know she's had her feel of taking
care of kids no that's right oh my god
uh she would be amazing but i don't know
we just kind of like being
we're sort of gypsies we're always all
on the road we're like all over the
place we
like we travel so much yeah we like not
having to really answer to
anything like oh you know they have to
be in school so we need to be here right
they need to survive so we have to feed
them
yeah but we never we never say never we
know we're like
if a
child needed a home in a few years and
we have a place to take care of
a child you never know if we adopt well
if i read that you adopt a child i'm
just going to be i'm going to be like
liar
she said she wasn't excited
um
[Music]
hey life assured listeners business wars
is a podcast from wondering that brings
you the full stories behind some of the
biggest business battles in history in
their new season you'll hear about the
fight between espn vs fox sports to
dominate the sports television industry
espn is the american cable network that
plays the trail for around the clock
sports coverage athletes even change the
way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn versus fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app hey life is short listeners
wonderize even the rich podcast is doing
a two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of patti hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity in a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patty was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
i'm totally exploiting your time now but
we just have a lightning round if you
don't come on
yeah um what is your most commonly used
emoji would you say
um the the cry one like laugh cry oh
yeah not like tear sad
yeah coming out of the sides yeah like
this is so funny i'm crying out of the
side of my eyes yeah um
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play i know you
have great stuff about the swimming swim
team that you joined well definitely
wouldn't be a swimmer
but you're a tennis player right i would
be a tennis player yeah i was a i played
tennis in college i loved it i still
love it but would you have your favorite
players
um i mean i was always uh
liked um
nadal and
oh god why can't i think of his name the
really sweet guy that one uh sweet guy
um uh oh oh oh my god that nadal is
played yes why can't i think of his name
i don't know i why can't i i should know
this too he's uh swiss you know it'll be
fun for people because they're going to
be yelling if this is dylan they're
going to be like it's blah blah blah
he's like michael jordan god he is like
the michael jordan of tennis
it's almost like if you google tennis he
would come up he says
i can't believe i can't think of this oh
this is crazy we should not know it
better better
yes there we go steve federer take away
my tennis card yeah oh my god roger
federer oh [ __ ] of course he is sweet
right
he wouldn't describe it's funny that you
knew he was sweet before you knew his
name um
if you if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what what
would it be one snack food probably a
snickers bar okay i like the snickers
yeah
do you like the almond ones the ice
cream ones um yes those are good too
yeah the ice cream ones are good but i
love those uh i like they're just a
regular old
old school snickers yeah they satisfy i
don't do you remember those commercials
where it's just like if like if you're
uh like just eat us snickers and your
everything will be better it's for local
it's for low blood sugar people yeah i
identify with those because i turn it
maybe you're like should they turn into
joe paschie yeah they were just like oh
this is i'm feeling down taking snickers
and like everything's like i
it's it's kind of true it's really
effective
um hopefully they'll send us a lot of
free product um what's your is what was
your favorite is there a movie that you
um that was really like meaningful to
you as a kid that you revisit a lot um
that brings you a lot of comfort maybe
during the pandemic i don't revisit a
lot but i had i went through a phase of
watching
the sound of music a lot when i was a
kid i like
memorized all the songs i was singing it
all the time but i did i did get to
interview julie andrews at the read
premiere of mary poppins oh wow and that
was like i mean i was like so star
struck
so what was that like did you get to
tell her that do you get to have that
moment with him i mean i think everyone
in the world is like
yeah she's like oh thank you she's got
like thank you yeah yeah
uh she was so gracious and lovely i've
heard that yeah it was just that move
that i oh i so right after college
before i moved to la i lived in spain
for a year and i would go to different
countries for like three weeks i would
travel around and i went to austria oh
okay and went on the sound of music tour
it was me
it was me and like six old people in a
van
and they were like playing all the
soundtracks and yodeling yodeling and
like we were stopping at all the spots
that they had in the movie we ate
apple strudel and i was the happiest
i've ever been that's so funny i think
that movie still does something for me
isn't that funny i would never have
guessed that um i remember playing max
in a summer theater production yeah i
had such poor rhythm that i would uh i
had to sing that song and it came on
like a downbeat and it was it was in all
the famous love affairs the lovers had
to struggle and i kind of like spoke it
but i had to give myself a word to come
in on the uh
yeah
uh that's really funny
what's your um what is your go-to
karaoke song speaking of sound um i love
don't stop believing oh yeah
i said believing
we've been saying my brother and i with
whom i do the show we watch a lot of the
bachelor and i've noticed a lot of the
bachelor contestants say um they add
like a k to the end of ing words have
you noticed that like really yeah i went
like running
running running
walking
you're laughing
that's weird i'd listen for it once you
believe
yeah um
i also love the song uh total eclipse of
the heart i think that is a great
karaoke song
bunny tyler yeah
the
[Music]
that's good it's uh it's all for karaoke
baby oh man i would love to go karaoke
with you do you have a place do you have
a place in l.a i don't no i just you
know whenever whenever one pops up i'm
i'm usually in line yeah i like it i i
prefer i get a little nervous around
people now but uh but i like the private
rooms i like the like yeah koreatown
brass monkey was always fun used to go
there a lot where was that one in
burbank that was uh oh yeah mr belding
always hung out there dimples dimples
yes that was like the place i remember
ever no and they would give you the
little tape of um they would give you
the tape and they would put boas on yeah
i mean that place was a hit yeah yes
all the actors who were like spent their
day active performing yeah just like
couldn't get enough of performing and
would do it like after work and the guy
that played mr building was always there
that's right he was
um who who was your speaking of mr
belding who was your first celebrity
crush
i mean it probably was zack morris it
was not it was not a lady it was that's
a rosie o'donnell turn it was uh yeah i
was a zac i love zach morris
uh from save by the bell i thought he
was a dreamy a dreamy guy and i love
jonathan from new kids on the blog no
kidding yeah the gay one okay that's
what you knew
you could i was like i feel
that's really funny well maybe that's
why you identified with rosie
o'donnell's tom cruise fixation maybe
like yeah she
you just you knew there was nothing that
was ever gonna happen
yeah what's funny i i met um brandi
carlisle the other night and i remember
thinking um and she's so like charming
and cute i remember thinking like
i don't know what that means i know
she's a lesbian woman um
uh if if you had to get a tattoo what
would you get uh and where oh man i
first off i'll never get a tattoo
because owie
yeah i know how we know
yeah so you'd have to get on a a part of
your body that doesn't hurt as much it
needs to be a very strong part of my
body that can handle it like real
callous i mean if i'm gonna get
something i guess i would want it to
like be a little artsy
yeah you know i don't want like an eagle
you know like all over your back
yeah like a ben affleck tattoo yeah like
you're like what
yeah
that was a wild reveal that was a very
wild reveal
i would have never i never saw that
coming
i would i wouldn't want all the colors i
would just want like something like like
us a word or something yeah and
something
cursive yeah yeah
like dainty yeah maybe your grandma
a giant a giant cross on my arm
i'm not religious but this is a
misleading
little
people go for it man yeah justin
timberlake style um who who would you
want to play you and your biopic in the
fortune
fortune movie i mean probably the person
that looks most like me
so shirley is their own right i was
gonna say i would
i didn't want to like just assume i mean
probably my twin charlize oh yeah you
know oh i'll yeah just put a curly wig
on her and call him she could play you
for sure yeah i could see that i
actually could see that
i could see her doing that um uh yeah so
again
her or
richard simmons probably isn't doing
acting these days
well don't count him out if i've learned
one thing no it's your turn yes yeah i'm
gonna turn the tables on you i did meet
him and i said i said oh my god i
i tested for snl and i
um i impersonated you he goes no kidding
he goes oh
well did you have fun
that's what he said i said yeah he is
okay
oh but there was a there was a little
bit of like
there's a slight bit of uh it was more
of like what like that he didn't ask you
to do it
no no but i did go to his class you
remember he used to have those classes
at slimmins back in beverly hills yes
this is a long time ago yes i did uh he
encouraged people to show up and like
jazzercize outfits
so i wore that outfit so he and i you
know
no kidding yeah did you do it uh how
much of it was about just
being in the class with richard simmons
how much as and how much of it was like
just wanting to like exercise uh it was
all about being around
okay i'm sorry
wait was it like a sweat to the oldies
thing it was it was like all it was all
like positive and just moving your body
but it wasn't like you know one of these
crazy classes in l.a where you're like
sweating
he
she was one of those pop culture figures
that
even before i knew what gay was
and i don't know that he's ever
i don't think he's ever we probably
shouldn't yeah i have no idea because
he's never talked about it yeah he's
never told me anything he had it i'd
never told me it either okay so maybe we
shouldn't speculate he's retired now
he's just living his life yeah so we
shouldn't speculate and like
but
he seemed so
comfortable with himself and his well
he's
yeah i mean he you know he was he
committed his whole life to
helping people lose weight and feeling
very positive yeah that was his whole
life yeah so who cares if he's good yeah
who cares
um
what is your favorite speaking of what
is your favorite fruit
it would be probably bananas okay
that's it
that checks down
it's a perfect food
i like i like them uh in smoothies and
stuff too yeah of course uh i
i like apples apples and bananas yeah
you have a favorite apple you have a
go-to like um like a fuji uh okay
we asked the hard-hitting questions here
fortune oh fuji i know this is like i
i'm starting to get so controversial
with you uh
who is your favorite muppet
um
you know what i could not name one okay
uh it's honest we
like miss piggy yeah yeah sure yeah i
mean probably kermit was my favorite
it's hard to beat so you didn't grow up
watching the muppets
i did to an extent but i don't know like
the secondary ones i i know like kermit
and miss piggy were you a sesame street
fan
uh yeah i watched sesame street yeah big
bird and yeah yeah an oscar and
sure all those people yeah i don't know
such a big part of my childhood i always
ask people because it can be a
touchstone um or not uh
your go-to pizza topping
your this is controversial okay
pineapple
no if people have been saying that
lately uh and it's funny my girlfriend
said
hers is uh
she loves the pineapple too i've never
been with anyone who likes pineapples so
on pizza italian people get very
i know
about it which i get it's not it's
sacrilegious i know but i like it you
know
why am i special is named what it is i
like the sweet and sweet salty yeah i
asked stanley tucci on the show that and
he was oh nothing
no he just wants cheese purist he's a
purist wow yeah i mean he's hardcore
italian hardcore uh yeah i felt
immediately self-conscious about even
like bringing up toppings
don't put anything on my pizza yeah cut
this part out too because publishers got
really upset um uh do you prefer dogs or
cats
i have two dogs so i'm gonna go with
dogs they might be listening um yeah
they would be upset uh the beatles were
the rolling stones would you say um
the beatles yeah do you have a favorite
a song that you would like if you could
hear beetle song now you're at a bar or
you go to the jukebox i mean i like god
only knows it's one of their later ones
right
no that's some beach boys but it's but
it's similar but they were so influenced
by it
beat the beach you know i love the beach
boys yeah um
you know hey jude
classic hard to beat i met i met a jude
the other day and
she was a little drunk and she said yeah
i'm jude
this is where i met brandi carlisle and
brandon just played uh
let it be i think and she was like yeah
i was mad that brandy didn't play
hey jude and i was like well that's a
little weirdly arrogant i know right you
only want to hear songs with your name
in it um but i said she was like i i
said were you named after hey jude and
she goes of course of course and i said
of course i don't know and i go what
about there's jude the obscure the um
and and she she goes well that's rather
pretentious
yeah and i said that and then that was
the the end of our interaction
yeah but i guess it is let it be is a
really good one too
yeah that's one of the best um
do you prefer seinfeld or friends
um i did want more friends like watching
friends more yeah no no shame in that i
like a rom-com you know com
that was like comedy and rom-com
all-in-one totally yeah
yeah um would you want to be was that is
that something you would want to do
being a rom-com write a rom-com heck
yeah yeah absolutely
yeah billy
just did that yeah he just did bros i
mean i think in general the industry has
to get back to more of the light movies
the comedies and the rom-coms
it's so heavy in
the marvel and i know that stuff is
great and the action stuff but people
love that lighter stuff
oh man you're here i want them to i want
to see that i want to see
that hopefully get made more yeah me too
um and and uh what are two adjectives
that you hope people use to describe you
after not that not to be morbid but
after you've gone what are what are you
if you could witness your own funeral
what are two words that you'd like to
hear people use
um
that
i was
silly and positive
yeah well
based on the little based on our brief
interaction i would i would testify that
i would if someone said that at your
funeral and i'm
there
to say that you would go before me i
would say yes i agree she was very silly
and positive she was those are two
things to aspire you know
i mean at the end of the day you just
wanna my goal in life is just to make
people feel good
yes and i think if you stay positive and
you you stay silly you people tend to
walk away from your interaction feeling
that way i totally agree i'm looking for
this quote um because it reminded me a
fortune of this quote from not to
completely dwell on
uh brandi carlisle i've just been
listening to you
i like randy myself oh man she's great
i've been following her for a while oh
yeah i think i saw her like in 2005 at
the
el rey or something oh man okay so
you're like an original yeah yeah i've
just recently discovered her but i can't
stop listening to this album and she's
got the song called stay gentle you just
reminded me because there's a line uh
where she says keep the eyes of a child
it's it's kind of about what you're
talking about
that sounds i i think that's something
to really aspire to to see the you know
to maintain that kind of child like uh
yeah for sure
yeah yeah well you've seen so much
there's so much negativity out there you
know and
you can find it anywhere you look
especially online so oh [ __ ] you i i
gravitate towards the more positive
the more uh lighthearted yep yeah you
know like that's not stuff that makes
you feel good well thanks for adding
that to this show and and to my day
because it was my pleasure i'm glad i
got to talk to you likewise yeah i loved
your again we're going to talk a lot
about your special at the uh the outro
on the intro and
thank you for that because it's so it is
so good and people need to see it um not
that they haven't uh and and your and to
your tour where people can find all the
information on your instagram and stuff
yeah i'm i'm going truly all over the
country uh at fortunefeester.com you can
find out if i'm coming to a city near
you we're doing
lots of theater shows and people are
coming out it's so fun so great people
will come join us well i i hope to see
you out there because i'm i'm sure a fan
of yours and so i'm a fan of yours
i've watched you for years and it's so
neat talking to you oh thanks i'm glad
you were you weren't like i actually
spoke to you years ago and you were a
dick on the right i never interviewed
you okay this is our first interaction
oh good well it was it was a lovely one
i'm really excited thank you thank you
thanks for having me um cool i'll see
you out there all right at the show
awesome thanks fortune
thanks for taking the time oh my
pleasure
[Music]
so that just happened
yeah she it's real like
she's a bit like a mcconaughey
yeah
there's a there's a real laid back i
really like listening to her is it
doesn't she have a soothing
she does have a really soothing voice
yeah and a beautiful singing voice yes i
know that came out that where did that
come from
it was really impressive
yeah it was i know and and i think she
knows it's impressive do you yeah
because she like
really launched into it and and i'm sure
she's been told that it's impressive
sort of chuckled proudly yeah but it's
really good she should be proud of it
it's also she she does a lot of karaoke
she's such great resonance in her voice
speaking and singing a lot of resonance
yes and the southern accent it's hard
for you or for anyone who doesn't have a
southern accent to do an impression of a
southern accent without sounding
like offensive and condescending yeah
well her voice is not only does she have
great resonance but there's the kind of
laid back and i i at the risk of
sounding uh like i'm stereotyping
southern people based on their accent
there is something about that accent i
think that
is it's a little more relaxed sounding
yeah
and i think when someone has that accent
it is just sounds like they're more
relaxed
at ease so she sounded to me like a very
chill relaxed like easy going person i
may be this may be totally out of my ass
but um that's a southern expression but
is it because more time in the heat more
time in the powerful so you're going a
step further in trying to uh just
explain the stereotypes just
anthropologically if there's a
throughput technologically if there's a
way to explain like the laconic nature
of it the kind of nice work nice use of
the word location i think i've been
sitting on that one for how long we've
been doing the show i don't think i've
ever said that but it is it's always
struck me as kind of like maybe use the
heat i wonder if it's the heat and
because you don't hear a lot of like
well jack mcbrayer but like not many
like
there's no one like jack
no he is from i think jack might be from
another planet if i had to the best
planet yes yeah much
not colonized no i don't want to take
away whoa no i didn't handle oh wow
that's what that's my imperialistic
nature yeah fortune feamster
i found it fascinating that she didn't
fascinating resonating that she didn't
realize that she was gay until
watching that lifetime movie and i know
she talked about it in her special
but
it really
i mean obviously i believe her it's just
so hard for me to understand that
because
especially when she was talking about
watching baywatch
uh how would you not know that
because i remember watching people you
knew you were heterosexual then i knew
why i liked baywatch but uh because of
david hasson
and she presumably she knew why she
liked baywatch right i i i don't know
why else you would like bay unless you
well there's other reasons to like
baywatch it's like but it's i can
imagine liking the plots the stories
yeah the stories it's it's fun to
uh watch david hasselhoff if you if
you're attracted to david hasselhoff
well again that's attraction that's
about a physical attraction so and it's
like fun plot you like the characters
maybe you get into the relationships
like
aj and hobie and no i know that you i
get that you watched it but like but
wouldn't those be secondary to the the
draw the initial i mean the fact i think
so i think so that's that's my point is
that for me it was like oh why else like
this is the main reason people watch the
show but maybe
that's not why she she didn't realize
why she was watching the show why she
was watching the show at the time right
drawn to it she didn't know why she was
exactly she just thought she's liked it
well i it's funny i i was um
i just read a thing in buzzfeed about
actors who had only done one part one
like significant part and then they left
the business and
one was to charlie from charlene the
chocolate factory i freaked the actor's
name but he was offered like a three
picture deal after that movie came out
it was a big hit and he became a
veterinarian he turned it down but
another one gwen stefani was one from
the aviator never did a movie again
after that um but one was uh the girl
from the child actor from actress from
neverending story who played the
princess
and i remember being so
she was older than me she was like an
older woman i remember being so drawn to
her
but i didn't exactly know why you know i
couldn't like at my
like it was six-year-old brain right
couldn't articulate oh it's because of i
guess it's just how she looked and
presented herself like there was no
genital evidence for why you're watching
no that's a good point that's a good way
of putting it genital evidence would be
a good name for something
yeah
it's like beard energy but see when i
watched and i think i'm around the same
age as fortune theme sir when i was
watching
baywatch
i knew exactly why i was watching i know
but but here's the difference i
grew up
uh heterosexual
which was
not it was taboo exactly there wasn't
any struggle to be heterosexual yeah it
was so i can't imagine
that like having those feelings and
you know wrestling with that which
everyone does in some way unless you're
not everyone i guess not some sexual
people but um
wrestling with like just the new
feelings the rush of like
you know hormones and then
and and then having it be inherently bad
like yeah that's societally bad it's
scary yeah yeah there's something really
fascinating to me about the concept of
exposure when it comes to sexuality
where
which is i think such a like the main
good reason why
shows like will and grace and shows that
promote
diversity
are good because
before like she was talking about that
before youtube before will and grace
before ellen before all this she was
coming of age and so for her it was like
she didn't
know about i mean like she said she knew
what gay was but if you don't see
examples of it i know around you in
society on tv
then
it really makes it hard to connect well
to like know who you are it's so that's
why like you know it's important to have
totally i think that's why we talk about
this a lot a lot of that um and the
hostility toward people
different who are just different is it
comes from that it's just the unknown i
think people fear the unknown right and
i for a long time gay um representation
was just
gay life was unknown gay
relationships were the story you talked
about grandma where she saw the
the gay couple in the restaurant and she
was she wasn't like ew gross no but she
was like fascinated
i'll never forget you i mean she was
like and look do you think they are you
know she couldn't um and they clearly
were they were very like demonstrative
and like affectionate but she um yes she
had never seen it and and that's also
true when i went to west hollywood for
the first time when i went to la i had
never really seen we even grew up you
know we grew up in a fairly progressive
place because we did theater growing up
so i was exposed to that affection like
gay affection as a kid yeah i have to
say i think for where we grew up that
time not that we were like the paradigm
of like
no phonetics no it was but different
than north carolina where she's from for
sure i knew a lot of people in college
who i suspected might be gay and but
couldn't be because i went to a more
conservative school
and uh i think that's totally different
and like almost across the board i i was
i was right about yeah them being gay
and now they're out thankfully they're
out and so you have really good you're
bragging about your gate i guess i am
yeah because i am interested in
human sexuality and when like someone
knows something like that and and in her
special she talks about the lifetime
movie as being like the
you know the catalyst for her coming out
but i it seemed like maybe she was
playing with the idea before i i didn't
know how to exactly to ask and i didn't
want to dwell on it for too long because
i didn't want the whole thing to be
about like her sexuality um
but it is interesting to me as somebody
who is not gay i i find things those
things of course and in her special
she
talks about not knowing she was gay and
then eventually figuring it out and
coming out to her family and
and she when she told her brother he was
like uh duh yeah
right
right no [ __ ] yeah they seem like she
seems like she's from a really like
pretty progressive it sounds like yeah
and her mom was really cool about i like
that what she said about like the mom
was only afraid that it might make her
life because i i would i think every
parent probably can relate to this that
there's a fear that it'll make her
journey in life more difficult sure
which again which is another reason why
the change that has has happened is so
important because i don't think that
exists as much anymore maybe in certain
parts of the country should we read a
letter okay let's let's do it
this is from whoa britian britian
roberts b-r-i-t-t-i-a-n
never seen that name
britain brit how would you say that
britain britain they might tell us
subject love the pod okay hello justin
i'm 24 year old female listener from
aberdeen south dakota i've never i've
never been to south dakota i'd like to
go isn't that never been no
i've never aberdeen i've never been you
would like it back to britain it's weird
how much a simple podcast has aided in
my everyday survival the human mind is a
tricky one and i've come to realize how
much your energy and your ability to
make me laugh so goddamn hard every day
is worth mentioning mentioning in an
email ah an email that i just messed up
reading
thank you britian that's really nice to
hear it it is um try saying the name
more casually britian pitching
or casually britain
why are you doing it so there's an eye
in there that i feel like are you so
delicate about the tease
yeah i guess it's hard you have to hit
the t's you did pretty or brilliant
brilliant pretty brilliant it might be
brilliant
pretend okay
i hope she tells us
okay back to brilliant
uh which by the way why are we dwelling
on her name it's such a great it's a
unique name it is okay if i could ask
you one thing it would be
what's one thing you could tell your
younger listeners about holding on for
the good parts of life i'm struggling to
find the point and depression is beating
the [ __ ] out of me more than i'd like
others to know loneliness i guess is a
topic i wish you could cover it in a bit
that is wow well i don't think that's
sorry i wasn't prepared for that pivot i
don't think it's specific to younger
listeners first of all the idea of being
lonely and depressed and um having
existential crises i think that's
that can happen throughout life for one
thing she says holding i think she's
holding out for the good parts of life
or holding on to the good parts of life
um that this is a really important thing
i want to make sure i say the right
thing or something that might be
valuable
to her um
young people might be struggling with it
more and i've been you know on the news
you hear those reports about how
depression is is
rising exponentially
and i think a lot of it and i find
myself struggling with this
when i'm on social media too much i
really think that is a huge um that has
a lot to do with it um it's it's
constantly
you know uh
forcing you to question your own value
your own worth as it relates to others
haven't they've done studies yeah that
link depression rates yeah to social
media usage and it's really bad it's
really bad i mean i think that is that
is good advice yeah so i think if we're
gonna like pinpoint some culprit um
i would say and i've found just
anecdotally but my own experience has
been that
when i'm off it for a length of time if
i go on vacation or if i'm doing a job i
am
exponentially happier i feel that i
don't feel and not that much less
informed no you know because what are
you missing the things you find out what
have i been telling you about lately is
like crap crap which bachelor is broken
up and who ben affleck and j.lo were
seen at the thing you know it's you just
told me about that big ben affleck back
tattoo oh that's amazing
but that's also like two years old
people who know him it is oh yeah that's
old news
um anyway uh
so i that might be helpful
britain but um
i i and i think that might lead to other
things it might lead to getting out into
the world and experiencing the world a
little bit more especially in south
dakota i imagine there's so much natural
beauty there
um also i think it's important to i mean
it's kind of like what i was saying
before to remind yourself that
it's not uh this is not about young
people you know this is not so it's
don't set false expectations where it's
gonna get better once i get older i'll
have figured it all out you know you
have to realize that like every person
goes through
something you know every person has
their own struggles so
don't make it i wouldn't make it about
your age that's a good point
yeah but i'm trying to remember that age
too where i was you know because there
is a sense that
um there's so much i remember being i
mean it's overwhelming it's overwhelming
there's a lot and like what do you do
what and and then you start questioning
too uh your purpose and i mean those are
heavy concepts to wrestle with and um i
think we've all
i i guess if there's some way you could
remind yourself or if you could
really acknowledge that everyone
experiences versions of that you know
what's weird and i just realized this in
a strange way i think one of the things
i like about being a little older
is that there are fewer options for me
now oh yeah in general you know like not
that a professional sports career was
ever on the table yeah but now that i'm
40 years old it's true it's definitely
not you know it's true so it's just i
mean that's a dumb example obviously but
well there was a 40 year old offensive
like he was the oldest i just saw that
it made me feel good and i like that tom
brady is in his mid-40s too but but in
general i think the older you get
kind of the more limited things are for
you but when you're in your early 20s
it's like you got the whole world in
front of you and that idea could be a
little overwhelming yes
that's true so i'd rather be a little
underwhelmed
sometimes
um i was just reading this gretchen
rubin book about happiness um if you if
you google gretchen rubin and happiness
uh because we're hoping to have her on
the show and and she talks about um she
did an experiment for a year about uh
which was how do i become happier she
was not that she was unhappy but she had
you know good marriage and kids and she
had all these things that she felt like
she should be happier
and
i really recommend it to you
britain because uh
it i i think there might be some really
practical tools that she lays out one of
which is
um they've done a lot of
studies there's psychological studies
where if you uh effect if you act happy
if you act
this sounds like fake it until you make
it it is that's where that expression
comes from there's there's real
scientific truth to that apparently if
you smile more it will it will make
christians smiling in a really weird way
but you have to it's got to be like your
real smile not like a fake
smile um fake it till you make it you
know go out there and be happy um uh
even if you're not necessarily feeling
it it might lead to you feeling it and
find things uh that make you happy and
they're also a lot of like you know what
it is too there are a lot of
expectations you have to do this you
have to do that uh that's helped me as
i've gotten older realizing i don't have
to please people i don't have to
answer this i don't you know
and that's advice from two idiots who
shouldn't be giving i know i know
um
but god what a great ques i really wanna
i think you did okay okay
back to brit
i'm just gonna collaborate now i feel
like i'm sure her friends call her brett
i do too
but maybe not i found so much light in
your charismatic tone and banter keep me
sane just another day um that's really
nice and
i think
find that there's got to be a way to
find that in aberdeen you know people
that uh that have that it's a beautiful
state yeah south south dakota um but
it's really nice that we do that i thank
you for saying that random she said brit
says random but i didn't realize you
were in the cast of he's just not that
into you you sure are yeah
lol your character is so real about the
truths in the dating world was that
genuine on how you felt at the time what
did you say what was your big line uh
uh if if he's not you know if he's not
calling you if he's not wasn't there a
line or
you're my exception oh yeah well that
was the rom-com line that i was afraid
to say you're my but that's the classic
line yeah you have to be sincere you're
my exception you're my exception and you
said that into the mouth of ginny
goodwin yes get friend at the front of
the show uh that's really nice to say
bro that was it she says was it genuine
on how you felt at the time i
you know i i wasn't very good at giving
that kind of advice
i should say i wasn't good at following
that advice but i found a lot of truth i
connected with that character because
like you said there was a lot of truth
um
in what he was saying and so that was
that was easy to connect with uh
unfortunately i didn't follow it in my
own
life but i was good at i was pretty good
at giving advice to people and around
the time that movie came out because of
that character
uh i would i would
be approached by a lot of people
um asking for advice dating advice um
around that around that time and i like
giving dating about i like because like
nick vale has that show i've gone on a
few times it's fun to
give advice to people i like trying to
help people that sounds really braggy
well it's also a lot easier to give
other people advice than it is yeah you
know give yourself advice and some of
the things you're doing in your own life
you know it's like
you see things more clearly
it's not about you when you're yeah was
that the end of the letter uh no no
there's a little bit more back to brett
um
hey next time you were around south
dakota let a girl know we'd laugh our
asses off no doubt britian
well the one thing that disappoints me
about this letter obviously is uh that
she never really clarified how to
pronounce her name
but maybe if i run into her in south
dakota i could learn that you wanted her
to in like spell it out phonetically
yeah
um because
foreign and people call her brit great
yeah me too um
right she but the both times she
referred to herself it was britian well
thank you britian yeah yeah go ahead no
no i was gonna say if other people would
like to write in and if you do have a
name that's a little more unusual
maybe um feel free to spell it out
phonetically so justin has an easier
time with it and are he gets hung up on
these things our email is life is short
at wondery.com
and thank you to our guests it's funny
that i think her name has both made us
both a little bit like tip toei pretty
and britain it's very like
it's very
genteel sounding uh and thank you to our
guest the very funny yes the very nice
she'd be a fun person to hang out with
wouldn't she i was thinking that yeah
fortune feedster you know what an easy
hang like easy fun hey yeah yeah like
good laugher she's a nice person she
does yeah i liked her a lot um i'm glad
we did that and thank you for yeah
thanks so much for doing it and
britain um let us know how you're doing
send us an update because um we would
love to see if our meandering
kind of like abstract advice was at all
useful i i would like to be that's
another thing i like about being older
is like i like
being able to maybe affect somebody
younger like giving advice like that
using whatever wisdom well you're going
to be a good old man
i'm kind of looking forward to it have a
good week everybody
petered out
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian law also produced by megan v
monaco and katie the allen senior
producer is michelle
slow it down for our audio engineer
sergio enriquez and uh we got an
executive producer up on this up in this
piece rams fan marshall louie
for a company called wondering i wonder
how they got that name i hope everyone
has a great week
[Music]
yeah well someone who would bark is
supposed to i guess that's not that good
it's close to fighting the blade is more
violent i mean it's violent barking is
just weird fighting you're hurting
somebody that's the difference that's
true but it's much more severe that's
true
barking is still a violent thing to do
to somebody emotionally i guess you
could say but very but you can't aggress
you can't physically harm someone by
barking at them that's a pretty big
difference i know but but if you if
somebody if if somebody bark did you
all bets are off then
oh yeah then it could lead to other
things i'm saying maybe worse things
like lifestyle fun maybe how can you
judge them
standalone things it's much would you
rather someone park you that by you of
course standalone thing that's all they
do to me exactly what about okay how
about this would you rather somebody i
wouldn't want to bargain you know that
would scare me
but if they bit me softly oh this would
you rather somebody like run up in your
face and like and they're like
barked and aggressively or somebody
running up and farting in your face but
being like i'm so sorry about that party
what are you talking about so easy i
thought you say we're biting softly
i'd rather be part of it by stuff like
even biting softly it might be crazy you
know it might break my skin like it's
scary too just someone coming and
fighting you mean yeah
oh am i getting farther though like
yeah you would i'd i'd be like grossed
out a little more face bark
my heart would be racing for like hours
if that happened to me
you